bonsoir aujourd'hui petit détour par le
département de la manche pendant quatre
jours le haras de saint lô a qu'à une
discipline en démonstration le horse
ball un sport de ballon qui demande
beaucoup d' adresser une grande
souplesse mais en attendant d'en savoir
plus place aux résumés des épreuves du
jour préparé par franck besnier c'est
l'image du jour
la britannique charlotte dujardin en or
dans le grand prix spécial de dressage
à 27 ans la championne olympique en
titre ajoute un nouveau trophée à son
palmarès
côté français ils étaient six engagés
dans cette journée premier à se
présenter ce matin sur la carrière du
stade d'ornano marc boblet c'est un
rescapé
31e au classement général hier soir est
donc éliminée pour une petite place il a
été repêché après le forfait de la
cavalière allemande
isabell werth mais la marche est trop
haute le parisien doit se contenter une
24e place
les acclamations des spectateurs du
stade d'ornano pour arnaud serre 20e du
général hier soir à 38 ans cet ancien
cavalier de horse ball est le meilleur
français de ce concours de dressage et
ça commence bien le piaf est ce trop en
suspension est parfaitement réalisé mais
son cheval robin de la faune rate ses
changements d'alu resserre un peu un
péché de jeunesse du cheval un peu de
fatigue aussi
donc j'ai quelques fautes sur les lignes
mais bon c'est pas ta garde également en
piste ce matin dans la deuxième manche
de l'épreuve de parra dressage samuel
katell ce dieppois de 28 ans amputé
d'une jambe a fait de l'équitation son
métier responsables de centres équestres
il participe à ses premiers jeux et ça
lui réussit plutôt bien il est cinquième
le lavallois vladimir vinchon avait lui
aussi beaucoup misé sur ces jeux il est
entraînée par marc andré morin un des
écuyers du cadre noir de saumur à la fin
de sa reprise il est 12e et passe à côté
de la meilleure a continué à travailler
on attendra la prochaine grosse échéance
pour envoyer et puis c'est une des
belles histoires de ces jeux anne
frédérique croyons 36 ans qui est
rappelé aux ics
elle a réussi à remonter à cheval sa
présence sur ces jeux est déjà une
victoire
je suis toujours au pôle hippique de
saint lô sur la carrière d'échauffement
et d'entraînement se trouve justement
l'équipe de france derrière moi nous
serons tout à l'heure avec marie quétier
qui vous donnera envie on l'espère de
venir voir du horse ball pendant ces
mondiaux et pourquoi pas en famille
regardez delphine zoé et lola devrait
être bien placé pour admirer le dressage
elles sont venues de rambouillet pour
partager ce moment
pourquoi en famille parce que c'est
rarissime ans et tous les quatre ans les
jeux c'est en france donc je pense qu'il
faut aussi encourager la discipline et
puis leur montrer un beau spectacle dans
le stade d'ornano la compétition a déjà
commencé sous le regard attentif de
spectateurs de tous horizons
être ici en normandie et vivre
l'évènement à 4 prend sens pour cette
famille dessus aignan
l'équipe est presque sentir les chevaux
d'ici et on les voit de près ça n'est
pas du tout la même chose que de les
voir à la télé c'est génial de pouvoir
voir tous ces chevaux c'est la branche
quelques mètres plus loin on retrouve
delphine cette pièce fait méchamment
pire il a du mal à entrer dans piques
vraiment la difficulté technique aussi
de nom je file s'allonge pensez pas
mobile est donc
bon ben voilà il ya des choux
son stationné
c'est entièrement
si certains sont plus dissipés d'autres
petits ont bien conscience de la
difficulté du dressage
je pense que si un jour je vais y
arriver
moi
à la sortie du stade la discipline n'a
peut être pas conquis tout le public est
ce que tu aimerais faire comme les
cavaliers mais ce n'est peut-être qu'une
question d'âge les jeux font des émules
parmi les plus jeunes retour à salou je
suis avec marie quétier membre de
l'équipe de france bonjour marie bonjour
alors que vous nous dire comment
fonctionne lance ball quelles sont les
règles alors le horse ball deux équipes
de quatre cavaliers qui s'affrontent sur
un terrain dans à peu près 80 mètres ça
galope ça virevolte faire trois passes
entre trois joueurs différents et
marquer les paniers qui sans extrémités
c'est une discipline qui monte est ce
qu'on peut espérer qu'un jour elle soit
disciplines officielles aux jeux
équestres mondiaux puisque je le
rappelle ici c'est en démonstration
c'est ça on est en démonstration
mais c'est le principe on commence en
démonstration pour un suis ensuite est
intégré de façon officielle dans les
jeux comme pour les jeux olympiques
c'est pareil et nous le but c'est
vraiment le but de cette organisation
on espère passer de façon officielle
dans les jeux et que être présent au
canada dans quatre ans merci marie et
bien merci
on reste dans la manche puisque demain
aura lieu l'épreuve d'endurance
on attend près de 5000 personnes pour
cette compétition qui partira dès 7
heures du matin de sortie grosse
affluence donc et petits conseils
pratiques
regardez l'endurance c'est un circuit de
160 kilomètres répartis en cinq parcours
pour les gens qui ont acheté un billet
il est conseillé d'arriver sur le site
de sortie dès 6 heures du matin pour
assister au départ vers 7 heures sans
billets il suffit de se positionner sur
le bord de la route
cet endroit avec des parkings ont été
tout spécialement préparé pour
accueillir le public
on a imaginé tout un dispositif pour les
spectateurs qui peuvent se rendre sur
les plages de jullouville de kairon de
carole de dragey afin d'aller voir la
course à des heures bien précises
puisque les heures de passage ont été
communiqués il pourra voir les détails
des boucles et des horaires de passage
il suffit de se rendre sur le site
internet des jeux équestres mondiaux
en voiture le circuit est libre d'accès
la seule contrainte de circulation ce
jour là sera l'acte granville à branches
qui sera coupé de 7h à 10h au niveau de
saint pierre langers la première boucle
emprunté par les concurrents sectionne
rd 973 au niveau de la commune de saint
pierre langers donc là on est obligé
d'interrompre totalement la circulation
dans les deux sens pendant le passage
des chevaux qui s'effectue en deux
phases une phase aller une phase retour
il est donc conseillé aux automobilistes
qui ferait avranches granville ou
inversement de passer par la haye-pesnel
pour éviter le secteur
c'est la fin de cette page spéciale or
ce beau je vous rappelle que la
discipline est en démonstration ici
pendant quatre jours à saint lô pour le
tournoi des jeux équestres mondiaux
italie espagne belgique et la france qui
est favorite venez les encourager